we are with katerina nimsova katarina
you were leading the tournament for
quite a while but then
tough road
in the latter part of the event has led
to maybe a result you didn't want
what's your overall assessment of your
tournament
overall i'm i'm quite happy with my play
i'm really unhappy about my game with
arena crush i mean
putting like the moves aside like the
time management was just so awful just
unexcusable and that really kind of
brought me down and it was really hard
to recover and the loss after it was
just like
nothing so
uh i think it was really hard for me but
today i think i had great chances to get
back
i uh maybe if we can go back just to see
like i missed e4 her that she played
there but i thought i'm like close to
winning or something and we were down so
i was i was happy with that position
you were definitely way ahead
in this game i thought knight e3 is a
really strong movie because
it's a gorgeous beauty you're happy you
like the answer yeah that was that was
lovely when we saw that move and i think
quincy to just i need to take on d3
knight d5 just said the exchange and
yes right right well i
that's
what you did was also very strong but
you're saying that you saw this
you rejected it why because queen c5 i
was looking at okay queen c5 bishop g2
bishop g2 e2 g2 king h1 okay
and i was like i don't think bishop e4
works immediately
but i but why not just
keep it going you got the memories yeah
i know this
this is a lot of probably don't deserve
to win the game if i don't play this no
but the problem is after queen takes c2
like if there is no e4 at what moment
catch um go back back back yes okay
yes still back still
yeah queen takes c2 yes if there is no
e4 like it's absolutely winning
ah
but the engine gives rook takes on e4
here after e4
wow
yeah baby
yes
give me your oops oops
i did it wrong
can we just put that's a visual move
that's
e4
rook takes e4 you wanted to sacrifice
the exchange right so like i mean the
two bishops like on f6 f5 they are
covering the diagonal rooks are perfect
like i have
no problems with my positions i just
need to win winning position
but i mean exactly carissa played really
well and tried to hold on as much as
possible and
then she tricked me
i think i'm just tired my head just
stopped working
so close very nice resource
right
here
d2
yeah i would have
dealt with this push with no problem
because you can just move your bishop
back and all she's doing is trading
pawns because you can always block i
mean it looks so easy now but it was
just invisible for me it's always easy
on the side it's okay to see everything
we know the commentators
we're not in the middle of the heat
well you did still have a good result
you're guaranteed fourth place
i believe it's not that top of the level
that you want you'll be going home with
a little extra money and some good
experience yeah i mean i played last
championship i think 2017. so i think
this is a good comeback and
uh
i mean it's such a pleasure to be here
at santos chess club i want to thank uh
genie and rex singfeld for hosting it
here it's incredible it's it's amazing
experience to just be like upstairs and
playing and also you guys shout out for
doing such a great job with commentary
thank you all my friends and family are
saying how they love watching you and uh
how it's really exciting so thank you so
much all right pleasure we'll see you
tomorrow at the closing ceremony what's
next for you by the way
um next for me is writing my
dissertation i need to finish that
doctor
i gotcha from now on coming up coming up
that's on my agenda now
yeah baby i like that that sounds great
very nice very nice let me just uh
uh again we got to go back to the five